a lot of people are really angry about a
production of Shakespeare's Julius
Caesar and if you heard about it's a big
story they're mad because the plays
title character who of course is
assassinated on stage bears a strong
resemblance to President Trump
here's a photo of the guy in the lead
yeah he's got the long tie he looks like
Trump and the fact that he gets attacked
and killed in the play has people really
mad okay now since Fox News reported
this a couple of the plays corporate
sponsors have pulled out everyone's
getting upset here's what I don't get
okay everyone's complaining about this
Julius Caesar production no one's
complaining about another famous theater
revival that's been treating Trump far
more viciously this I think this is
really outrageous and no one's talking
about it check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
Regus they apparently chew on him for
two acts two entire acts but he's fine
in the end he's fine yeah
you